THERE'S BIG DEBATE TONIGHT
INVOLVING A SENATE SEAT IN OHIO
WHERE THERE IS NOT DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST KEVIN WALLING AND
AARON PER RENEE.
THAT THINK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING
US.
I WANT TO ADD LET KEVIN WAS
SAYING A LITTLE MORE CONTEXT I
WANT TO PUT ON THE SCREEN.
FISCAL YEAR 2022, 2.15 MILLION.
ON PACE FOR 2.3 MILLION AND THA
SINCE IT BIDEN TOOK OFF AS YOU
HAVE 3.59 MILLION.
BY DEFINITION, THIS IS A CRISIS.
A DISASTER AT THE BORDER IN THE
VICE PRESIDENT WHO IS IN CHARGE
GOES TO TEXAS AND FAILS TO GO T
THE BORDER.
WHAT YOU THINK?
>> IT'S A REPEATED PATTERN OF
BEHAVIOR FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION FROM CAMELOT
HARRIS AND FROM DEMOCRATS AS A
WHOLE.
SHE GOES TO TEXAS AGAIN FOR THE
SECOND TIME AS VICE PRESIDENT
AND DOESN'T GO FULLY TO THE
BORDER BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND SEE THE
CRISIS HER AND JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES HAVE PERPETRATED
AGAINST AT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU SEE THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY,
IT'S ABSOLUTELY OVERRUN.
DEMOCRAT STRATEGY IS BEWILDERING
.
IT SEEMS TO BE PUT YOUR HEAD IN
THE SAND.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE CRISIS AND YOU HAVE A
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN COMMITTE
CHAIRMAN AND PARASITE
FUNDRAISING.
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING EVERYTHING
EXCEPT ACKNOWLEDGING THE
REALITIES THEY'VE UNLEASHED ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
>> IT'S A FAIR POINT.
THE DEMOCRATS THAT DON'T WANT T
TALK ABOUT IT.
AT THE LEFT MEDIA YET DOESN'T
WANT TO.
REPRESENTED AT TONY GONZALEZ IN
TEXAS WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE TO VISIT ME.
HENRY CUELLAR IS A DEMOCRATIC
GONZALES IS A DEMOCRAT ESCOBAR
IS A DEMOCRAT.
SHE COULD VISIT ANYWHERE ALONG
THE BORDER.
THE FACT IS THEY PUT THEIR HEAD
IN THE SAND.
THEY'VE ABANDONED US ALONG THE
BORDER.
>> DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT HE
NOT VISITING THE BORDER.
>> CERTAINLY TO AARON'S PORT IT
IS IN A CRISIS.
I'M A DEMOCRAT IN YOUR PANEL
THAT IS WITH HIM TO ADMIT IT.
LOOK AT WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN DOING YEAR-OVER-YEAR
WE'VE BEEN SEARCHING RESOURCES
THE FISCAL BUDGET FOR MORE
PATROL OFFICERS ARE NOT BORDER.
MORE SECURITY IN TERMS OF
BUILDING MORE PHYSICAL WALLS.
GET MORE SURVEILLANCE ACROSS TH
BORDER WHERE THERE ARE DIFFEREN
TERRAINS THAT CAN BE SECURED.
THIS IS CERTAINLY A SERIOUS
ISSUE.
YOU POINT OUT THE NUMBERS AND
THEY ARE A HORRIFYING WHEN YOU
SEE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS.
IT'S A DIRECT RESULT OF THE
VIOLENCE THEY'RE PLAYING.
A LOT OF HUNGER AND FAMINE.
A LOT OF CRIME IN THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE.
IT COMING OUT OF COVID IN THE
DESPERATION TO CROSS A DESERT
WITH YOUR CHILDREN OVERT DAYS
LONG JOURNEYS TO GET TO THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE TO DO MORE WHEN IT COME
TO NOT JUST SECURING THE BORDER
ABOUT PASSING IMMIGRATION REFOR
THAT WILL FUNNILY TACKLE THE
ISSUE.
>> I WANT TO MOVE ON NOW IF I
CAN TO THE MIDTERMS BECAUSE IT
IS HUGE SENATE RACE OHIO.
A DEBATE TONIGHT BETWEEN JD
VANCE AND TIM RYAN.
>> BY THE WAY THAT'S THE BASE O
WHAT POINT TO IS A LITTLE BIT O
A LATE STILL WITHIN THE MARGIN
OF ERROR AND HERE IS A LITTLE
BIT FROM THE DEBATE.
>> IF YOU GET RAPED THEY SAY YO
HAVE TO HAVE THAT BABY.
A STATE-MANDATED PREGNANCIES OF
A RAPE VICTIM.
THAT IS SO FAR OUT OF THE
MAINSTREAM, IT'S NOT FUNNY.
>> THAT POOR GIRL WAS RAPED BY
AN ILLEGAL ALIEN.
SOMEONE WHO SHOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN IN THE STATE.
HE VOTED AGAINST BORDER WALL
FUNDING AND FOR MSD.
IF YOU HAD THAT YOUR CHILD, SHE
WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN RIGHT.
>> YOU CAN SEE THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT TO OF THE TOP ISSUES ABOU
ABORTION AND THE BORDER.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW THAT RACE
IS SHAPING UP.
>> I WOULD EXPECT TO SEE JD
VANCE TOO START TAKE A FURTHER
LEAD AWAY FROM TIM RYAN FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS.
AT THIS DEBATE I HAVE TO APPLAUD
.
HE PREPPED HARD AND SHOW THAT
TIME AND AGAIN.
HE DID NOT ALLOW TO MYINT TO
DEFINE HIS POSITION.
TALK ABOUT THE FACT HE BELIEVES
IN REASONABLE EXCEPTIONS AND IN
THE CASE OF THE TEN -YEAR-OLD,
HE SAID IT WOULD HAVE IT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED.
HE BROUGHT IT BACK TO A MUCH
STRONGER POINT.
TIM RYAN HAD NO EXCUSE FOR HIS
20 YEARS OF FAILURE.
SUCH THAT ARE REALLY AFFECTING
OHIOANS IN A WAY THAT JD VANCE
IS RELATING.
TWO MICE AND AND TIM RYAN CAME
OFF AS OUT OF TOUCH.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE HIM TAKE A
MORE SIZABLE LEAD OF THE RACE.
>> IT'LL BE CLOSE.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
IT IS GOING TO BE CLOSE NOBODY
TALKS ABOUT.
IT COULD BE PIVOTAL.
>> I AM RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
I COULDN'T DISAGREE WITH MY DEA
FRIEND.
I THOUGHT TIM RYAN HAD A GREAT
DEBATE.
HE WAS PERSONABLE AND TOOK THE
FIGHT TO JD VANCE OVER HIS
EXTREME VIEWS.
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO
ABORTION POINTING OUT THAT RAPE
TO AN INCONVENIENCE.
THAT SPEAKS VOLUMES TO WOMEN IN
THE BUCKEYE STATE.
IT'LL CERTAINLY BE A CLOSE RACE
OF IT 1.2 PERCENT RACE RIGHT NO
ACCORDING TO CLEAR POLITICS,
IT'LL BE A DOGFIGHT.
THEY HAVE ONE MORE DEBATE BEFOR
ELECTION DAY AND I CAN'T WAIT T
WATCH THAT WENT TO.
>> I KNOW YOU LIKE THE DEMOCRAT
IN THE RACE AS YOU ALSO SAID
BLAKE MASTERS DID VERY WELL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE BACK TO DEBORAH.